IEP sec, one of the most commonly used protocols for VPNs, so John, I've heard about
these security. IEP sec, one of the most commonly used protocols for VPNs, so John, I've heard about
these security associations in IEP sec, what's that all about? Well, first IEP sec, really important
for them to understand, not only because it's a tunneling protocol, it provides security,
it can be used as VPNs, but it's also built into IP version 6, and that's why, you know, there may be
a lot of questions on the exam that reflect on this, but yeah, security associations. That's how we,
because remember, this IP sec is something that operates at the network layer, and in fact,
it is IP that uses it, that's why it's called IP sec, but devices that operate at the network
layer, like routers, will use what are called security associations to connect to other devices
and other things. They're simplex, right, which means they only run in one direction. Correct,
so these security associations are what we call one-way simplex connections, so if you and I want
to talk to each other, how many connections do we need? Well, or a security association. If you want
to be able to talk to me as well, we need one from me to you, one from you to me, that's what simplex
means, it's like radio, right? Radio can only be received by your radio or the signals, it's one
way, that's what simplex means, so yeah, later we're going to talk about why there are four
required, but we need to get you to talk about something else before we get to that, but that's
what a security association is, it's simply a connection between devices and they are one-way
simplex connections, but here's why we need to keep track of these, because as a device that
operates at the network layer, I could be connected to you, but I can also be connected to other
devices at the same time, and so I don't need to keep track of those. Yeah, that's right,
that's why we need to keep track of some of these attributes that you see up on the screen here,
that's what security associations are. Okay, so now IPsec allows you to create a VPN, and obviously
you're supposed to send traffic data back very quickly, so that means you need to encrypt the data
very quickly, so that means we have to use symmetric cryptography, and now we have the problem of
key distribution, so how does IPsec solve that? Our students know exactly that, because we've
talked about that. The only type of cryptography that we can use in order to do things across
networks, because it's the only thing that's fast enough is symmetric, as Rob just said, and that
means we have to have the same key at both ends, and so I think we went through the Diffie Helmand
Key Exchange Protocol. Remember that, that mathematical magic that allows two different locations
to come up with the same secret, which can be used as keys, session keys to encrypt and decrypt,
so you may get a question that says, what's the key management protocol that IPsec uses?
Yeah, because it's not Diffie Helmand, right, so what is it? It's a version of Diffie Helmand,
everything is a version of Diffie Helmand, but in this case it's called IKE Internet Key Exchange,
it's just different math in Diffie Helmand, but it does the same thing. Yes, so remember that,
that's pretty important to understand. Now, next slide talks about the two modes, but these
really refer to the two services that IPsec can provide. Yeah, because it's a complicated protocol,
you've got a ton of options, it's the way you can do, and the first two options you have are
whether you want to run at an age authentication header or ESP encapsulating security payload.
So what's the difference? Authentication header just provides integrity, data origin,
and replay protection. So it's basically just integrity, and not one important thing.
Well, encryption. Encryption. Right. And that's what ESP provides. It's everything that
age provides, plus encryption. Sure. And we said that IPsec really provides two distinct
security capabilities, authentication, and encryption. That's what these two sub protocols really
provide. And yeah, I think you need to tell us what the next two things are here, the two modes.
It gets even more complicated. Yeah, because then you can run it in transport mode or tunnel mode,
and you'll recall John having talked about tunneling, tunneling means that you take a datagram,
and you put it within the datapart of another datagram, which means essentially that you add a new
header. And so that's the difference between these two modes. In transport mode, you don't do any
tunneling. You just reuse the original header. But in tunnel mode, you actually tunnel the
packets. You add a new header. Perfect. And so I think this next slide here, while looking a little
bit complicated, kind of shows how this all fits together. So we can first of all run in authentication
header mode, and then you can run authentication header mode in either transport mode or tunnel mode.
So when you're running in transport mode, you're just reusing your original header. You're adding
the authentication header. That's the AHP's, and you've got your data. And then in tunnel mode,
you're adding that new header. And then when you go into ESP, looks exactly the same, except the
big difference here is that you are encrypting the actual data. And so it's only running in ESP
mode. It's a VPN, right? Correct. Well, because a VPN by definition is tunneling plus encryption.
That was for you. It was a reminder. Yep. And so let's give people a good way to remember this,
because there's really four different ways that you can use this, correct? And so,
is there an easy way for them to understand this? Like authentication header transport mode means
this, correct? I don't remember the diagram, I guess? Yeah. Memorize the diagram. They may
ask you about any of these four different ways that really relate to authentication header and ESP,
whether in transport mode or in tunnel mode. And to bring it back to security associations,
this is why you need up to four of them. Because if you want both a connection and you want to
encrypt that connection, then you need two simplex connections in each direction.
Right. So if you remember that simplex, they're simplex connections. So if Rob and I want to talk
to each other in both directions, we need two security associations. But if we want both
authentication and encryption in both directions, you cannot host those two things across one security
association. You need one for each, meaning we need two in both directions, which would equal four.
Yeah. There you go. Bye, peace out.